I thought that the two worst categories
on Tick Tock were the random people
jiggling around and not very much
clothing and the creepy teachers
grooming their kids with all sorts of
weird sex stuff there is actually a
worse category a more grading category
that would be the woke religion tick
tocks this compilation of the very best
woke religion tick tocks is brought to
you by ring more from ring in a bit
first though my producers have given me
the compilation I have not seen them yet
I guess I'm going to have my mind
expanded man
take it away okay Bible stories for
Pride fun I'll be telling you a bunch of
little Snippets of different characters
who are non-gender conforming in the
Bible First off we have Jacob God
renamed Jacob is Israel and all of his
descendants became the nation of Israel
kind of an important dude but he didn't
always act so doodly whereas Jacob's
brother Esau was super hairy and liked
to hunt and be outside and be a manly
man Jacob was super smooth and liked to
hang out with his mom at home and help
cook and clean in the tent well take a
pause is the argument now have we gone
from a man trapped in a woman's body or
you know a hermaphrodite who is both
have we gone from that now to the basis
of transgenderism is that some men don't
play football what the hell well kind of
[ __ ] are you we've gone from hey women
are allowed to wear pants hey women can
go get a job or drink a beer to hey if a
woman wears pants she's actually a man
and needs to cut her breasts off that's
really that's really how far we've gone
here is that we've completely undermined
the idea that there is anything such as
gender expression we've actually gone
back to the idea that there is only sex
and if you in any way act a little bit
of feminate or a little bit masculine
then you've got to be the opposite sex
keep going next character is Joseph
Joseph is Jacob's son Jacob gave Joseph
a beautiful rainbow tunic Hebrew word in
the Bible to say the tunic is the same
word that describes the Garb that virgin
Daughters of the king would wear Joseph
was the first drag queen let's take a
pause there until what like the 14th
century or or later help help I'm being
repressed
people just wore big kinds of dresses
and gowns right like when you think of
Aristotle and Plato walking around
ancient Greece they weren't wearing blue
jeans and an Oxford button-down shirt
Styles have changed but there was much
more of a kind of similarity between
male and female dress because people
would wear robes right people ordered
togas
you're telling me that if if you're not
wow did you know that the the Garment
the word for for coat was actually the
same word that's used for a woman's coat
for a man's coat and a woman's coat like
first of all we still use the same word
today but also yes it is it is true
Fashions had kind of some similarity
there so you're saying because Joseph
had a colorful jacket he's actually
secretly a woman and no biblical scholar
had ever noticed that until
this lady on Tick Tock next up is
Deborah before Israel had Kings they had
judges the only judge that was a woman
was Deborah she was also the leader of
the military and kicked the Canaanites
ass in a setting where women were
treated like property and their value
was based on how many kids they had
Deborah said your gender standards roll
on someone take a pause there too
taking away even the discussion of
Deborah this is total retconning this is
totally a rewriting of history and the
Bible this idea that back then women had
absolutely no value and they were just
cast aside and treated as property
that's not true at all what are you
talking about so the most important
figures in the Bible many of them are
women the Eve is pretty important Eve's
not treated his property Sarah is not
treated as property Rachel has not
treated his property Rahab I mean go all
the way up to the Virgin Mary oh my
goodness oh my goodness gracious one of
the is the second most important
human figure in the Bible I would say is
a woman that the idea that they were
treated as property it's just not true
that's just a complete invention of
modern radicals radicals
who want to pretend that we live in a
much better world today than in the old
old-timey bad days because today you see
women have the great respect and freedom
to prostitute themselves on only fans
and make a wage living alone in a studio
apartment in a city by working at the
widget Factory for Mr McGillicuddy
coming to bed honey yes dear unlike Back
In Those Old awful days when women were
valued as the the matriarchs of their
homes and the Hand That Rocks the Cradle
is the hand that rules the world yeah
man things have gotten so much better
right I'm not so sure about that keep
going lastly we got all of our eunuchs
what is a eunuch most people think it
means a man who's been castrated and
also just being an effeminate man who's
not interested in women Jesus said that
there's three kinds of eunuchs eunuchs
by birth eunuchs who were made so by
others and eunuchs who chose to be
eunuchs you know what Jesus said about
them love and accept them all gender is
a construct and it's all affirmed in the
good book itself she makes a kind of
interesting point about Unix first of
all I don't think love and accept them
all up here is you know anywhere in the
Bible I think she I think that was kind
of a little revision that she added in
there but the discussion of Unix is very
interesting because it's true you
eunuchs in themselves eunuchs have
always existed and they do present in
themselves a kind of complication for
sex and gender expression the reason we
are failing to fight against
transgenderism is because we've taken
this really stupid scientistic approach
the same kind of Soul denying
scientistic approach that the Liberals
use to get us into this mess in the
first place when we deny such a thing as
gender expression of course there's
gender expression he was like a girl of
course getting to this woman's point a
man can act in an effeminate way a woman
can act in a masculine way people who
are castrati people who are eunuchs for
the kingdom of heaven or people who are
born hermaphrodites or people you know
that's a very rare occurrence but it has
happened on occasion and so what does
that mean well it raises a question for
us the current reductive stupid way
conservatives are talking about gender
is they say no such thing as gender
expression it's just X X and Y
chromosomes sure I mean that's a pretty
good indicator but no there is a gender
expression the reason transgenderism is
wrong is not that sex and gender
expression are the same thing or that
gender expression doesn't exist the
reason transgenderism is wrong is
because sex and gender expression are in
fact distinct categories
and we have a duty to express our gender
in a way that is in Conformity with our
sex it's not that they're not different
it's just that we have an obligation to
the to who we are to the way that we
were created I remember when when Matt
went to Africa and talked to the Maasai
people and he asked them what what is a
woman and the kind of giggly answer for
most people today would be well a
woman's someone with breasts you know or
a man someone with a phallus we're going
to be talking about the penis but the
Messiah people didn't answer that way
the Messiah people actually said a woman
is someone who does the duty of a woman
I thought that is a much more precise
and complicated answer than we're
getting from the the American
conservatives you know my schedule is
very very busy especially we're heading
into speech season I'm talking all over
the country all over the world actually
and I can rest easy because I love ring
ring alarm the protection afforded by
ring alarm is phenomenal I know what
you're thinking you're thinking Ring the
video doorbell company they have an
alarm yes they do ring alarm is an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself
even I can do it I'm not the handiest
guy in the world but ring didn't even
stop there ring has changed the home
security game with ring alarm Pro which
is why I have decided to team up with
ring when it comes to protecting my home
I've gone pro you got to be a pro just
like me okay ring alarm Pro is that
whole home security system it's got
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe it combines a security
system with fast Eero Wi-Fi 6 router
home security network security your
physical home your digital home you
protect it all with one device with a
ring protect Pro subscription which is
an amazing deal by the way I get
professional monitoring whenever I want
it for the ultimate piece of mind if
anything happens professional monitoring
can call you you can press emergency
services this season whether you're
traveling across the country for
speeches whether you're at your home
whether you're at the office make sure
you are protected with ring okay GoPro
learn more at ring.com Michael ring.com
Michael alright next video to all the
people who say they have to live by the
Bible exactly and use it to excuse
oppressive and ignorant thinking and
behavior such as they're only being two
genders because the Bible didn't mention
more than two genders the Bible didn't
mention electricity either Brenda if you
want to live your life entirely based on
what the Bible mentions go get a clay
heart in the middle of the [ __ ]
forest and never speak to us ever again
okay so the the good point that she
makes is that not every metaphysical
truth is articulated by name in the
Bible so the Trinity the idea that
there's God the Father God the Son and
the Holy Spirit who is the bond of love
between the father and the son the
Trinity is not explicitly named in the
Bible the Trinity appears in the Bible
and you can go through the text from
Genesis all the way up until the end of
the Bible to see the evidence of the
Trinity but it it is inferred it is not
just named out okay absolutely true
there are plenty of other things in the
Bible that are not explicitly named the
problem for her argument though is that
the fact that there are only two Sexes
is actually stated in the Bible
affirmatively it's not just that it the
third sex is omitted
in the beginning God created man both
male and female created he them and then
this is reaffirmed later on by Jesus in
the New Testament when he describes what
marriage is and he says a man and a
woman come together for this reason a
man leaves his family and joins together
with his wife and becomes one flesh and
what God has joined let no man separate
so her argument about electricity is is
a good argument and that can apply to a
lot of other biblical Concepts but in
this case the Bible is very very clear
male and female created he them all
right of of those two that that's really
easy the second gal did not make a very
good argument but I actually found her
kind of charming and endearing I was a
teenager once I made dumb arguments at
one at one point and she'd started to
almost make a good point and then kind
of just her own ignorance of the text I
think Got Her Off Track whereas that
first lady I mean she was just
completely completely not only insane
but putting things into the Bible that
just are not there and just reading her
own delusions into into the text so I
would have to say she is my least
favorite
please send me your least favorite woke
religion tick tocks and we will get to
them next time
[Music]